yes thank you for having me on the show
and congratulations to you all out there
and Aldabra at all are just amazing that
you've put this together you know I have
in my lifetime I'm from Fiji seen
pristine atolls and then see them
atrophy over the decades with the the
plague of plastic that we've set upon
the ocean it isn't just plastic of
course is it it is global warming -
certainly the Seychelles is amongst
those places that have been really hit
hard and I know in the 2016 coral mass
bleaching episode that it was very
difficult at the water temperature that
we see behind us that shouldn't really
go above 29 degrees for coral reached 30
degrees over for consecutive months
sometimes spiking at 31 degrees so coral
bleaching is here on the granitic
Islands a little bit here in Aldabra -
how important is it you think that the
world wakes up to the difficulty of
climate change and what that is doing to
the oceans
it's absolutely existential for us if we
even care a little bit about the
well-being of our children and
grandchildren this is probably the most
important thing facing humanity at the
moment climate change in ocean change so
there's there's no getting away from
that
unfortunately the ocean is in deep
trouble you've pretty succinctly put it
there in distinguishing between climate
change and things like pollution and
fishing I see it as two areas one is
imminently fixable which is the fishing
and the pollution side that is just man
management getting the laws in place and
and doing the business and I firmly
believe we can do that over the next
decade clean up the ocean and sensibly
manage our fish stocks and get into
sustainable aquaculture and all the rest
but there is a much more difficult
challenge that we're facing which is the
climate change challenge and that is
where we have to address our GHG
emissions with what we're putting into
the atmosphere because that is what's
really damaging oceans health you know
you're looking at things like ocean
acidification deoxygenation ocean
warming and as you say the effects of
all that such as
you know coral die-off and rising sea
levels yes and in fact I'm walking as
you're talking towards the ocean zephyr
which is the mothership for the
scientists of the nectar mission who
we've joined with and certainly when
I've been down in the submersibles we've
been taking some of those readings that
you mentioned there the salinity
readings the acidity readings and it's
really important isn't it to say to
people that actually the extra carbon
dioxide we're putting into the
atmosphere is being absorbed in there
and it can't keep doing it already we
heard from the principal scientist she
saw in the antarctica evidence of shells
melting because of acids the acid in the
water the carbolic acid in the water so
really change is already happening isn't
it absolutely right and you know there's
the the continuing and acidification of
the ocean is purely related to the co2
levels in the atmosphere so yeah that
that is going to make life things very
difficult life in the ocean you know you
think of any calcium carbonate based
life form like shellfish or vertebrates
you know how are they going to form
their skeletons if they're being if this
rising acidification is being applied to
them so that's that but the ocean
warming side is so tragic and that's
just obviously as the atmosphere warms
with our greenhouse gas emissions the
ocean warms as well because the ocean
takes most of that ocean of our wants
that we're producing is absorbed in the
ocean so in the past we've thought the
ocean is big enough to take it but now
we realize it's not and we're seeing the
effects for one thing sea level rise in
our age too expands only one way to go
up which is now only one way to go which
is up you know think of the ocean as a
bathtub there's only one ocean so as you
expand up grow the levels and think of
the not just the pacific islands and
atolls like elder brother' which will go
underwater but think of those coastal
areas like Bangladesh you know river
deltas which support tens of millions of
people all going underwater where are
people going to go so you've also got
with ocean warming the tragedy of coral
reefs the the thought that by the end of
the this century we could be in a
position where there are no longer any
coral reefs for me coming from Fiji
brought up on a coral coast this is
tragic beyond belief and you know it's a
kinder saying there'll be no more
forests on land the coral reefs are the
bunkers of biodiversity for the oceans
and to take them out of the picture you
know it could well be the taking out of
the the ocean ecosystem and therefore
they're taking out of our global
ecosystem and therefore us yes and
indeed people say don't they that they
are less than 1% of the landmass but 25%
of the diversity while you're talking
we're right by ancient coral here it's
about 125 thousand years old probably
lifted up as sea levels drop at some
time in its history there are whole
corals here actually some mushroom coral
here a flat one but it does shows you
that this is what the living form of
this is what needs to be protected now
to keep the diversity that you're
talking about and certainly some of
those governments that you mentioned did
head to the g7 to try and make their
case governments like that here in the
Seychelles or the Maldives to make the
point you're making
you must feel as UN Special Envoy that
you want to bang heads against a wall
about this you must be so frustrated
about it yeah I'm in a different country
every week talking to governments and
conferences about the urgency of the
situation the predicament that Humanity
is in but the fact that we have a plan
where and the plan of course is the
Paris climate agreement and the
sustainable development goals in the
case of the oceans sdg 14 so we have to
be faithful to the implementation of
that plan and you know as you know there
are some that are sort of in denial
and that just means that those of us
that know the truth have to carry a
heavier burden and put you on harder and
when I say no the truth we get the truth
from the very best of our scientists
who've been assembled in the IPCC and
put out reports from time to time and
these scientists are not people from
another planet you know that they're
getting their information from the
weather offices of every country on the
globe and they collect those daily at
the World Meteorological Organization in
Geneva and this is the truth you know
there's no avoiding the truth so the
rest is obfuscation the truth is there